You know you might feel no need to mention on the radio when you are a little bit
and you say oh I was told I just gave you a story of my give me do you go.
She told me he's sorry what do you think Michael said
but they will argue with you about you really contributing to the loan.
Doing something they enjoy that he will be for me this being your home right here in this recession to get the word
lightly on your right side go straight.
We'll look at this like you see that it isn't said much here in the situation here because I mean it's a good thing to
say Are you crazy. And it was actually pretty funny.
What one of the things are slowly
but with a train here is that if you will strike straight down the songs I mean if you make the train cars pretty a
little bit more or less true here that's really really really what it said but I truly believe. Oh yes.
Or maybe yes yes and it was in the right. Especially if your brother was not here.
So they didn't want their picture but with all your mind that there is just over my shoulder with his shoulder.
Yes I see this.
This is this guy here she had a great write up to get you know he was a pleasure to work with the way you live
but I see what Larry here about six years.
Oh he would write about this right now in front of the little boy you're old enough to hear it was really ready to go.
I mean you can still feel like going well if he was all the way here.
Get a hold of this boy if one knew he was if he was real life Jimmy Jimmy Carter that you know I'm sure he would do the
plate races that you'll see that I'm sure the place for me will be specially if we get the yellow bottles
and yes OK Do you know this he was absolutely. He was a good looking. Well I mean I don't like to hear you.
Even though you're with us. I'm just hearing some of the oh yes. You wouldn't be able to really leverage. Yeah right.
He was saying you're right the city where from. Oh yes. Did you come to Sydney to get yourself here. That's right.
Well I think we'd better make sure it was really very fulfilling it's really very well where they are getting the good
life. Dr Elizabeth tested. GEORGE NEGUS Yeah exactly.
Are you enjoying much this week we're sorry you didn't get here just like you did to get anyone else.
Yeah you lose your brain
when you feel you want to be really really I mean one of the people we're just getting people who feel relaxed.
That's right here along here. What is your problem.
Here's a program visual Well look I guess if you just see what the heroes look like here look at the Joan right
or the close up of the right. It's just really this is a boy story we're very curious.
I just let it show that he was not how it was this is the record we do.
Really really well run says he did this it was Riley was writing tells the victim to because it would be just a really
really good script but he was used to talking to be entertaining and he would cross talk to feel right.
And he must've felt really ridiculous.
And it was a tale of zero eight zero nine just on that night and they put it into a dramatic fall because he could.
I'm judging by the think that if you make me illiterate believe it or of the drug. Yeah you know me. Oh no.
And it can't be a little old right in here a lot of people can fool some of the really nice living ten meters behind
the man right here but honestly this is a ton of it was thrilling
and I love it a little bit like a little boy here I know I mean because it might This is for me it was bad for you
and good night from Hollywood this riles on this shelf that you write.